the start of three days of mourning in
Brazil
grieving not just the football icon but
the figurehead who United the nation
and in the coastal city of Santos
remembering Where it All Began for Pele
as a 15 year old
and where he spent most of his playing
career becoming the greatest player
perhaps of all time
a legacy honored in Santos's Palais
Museum where fans and former players
have come to pay respect surrounded by
medals trophies and jerseys
the world owes Pele I was lucky to be in
this world anyone who's seen him playing
knows he's the best ever and he always
will be he was extremely important for
the city of Santos
had all the attributes left and right
foot heading and shooting and a World
Cup record unmatched the only three-time
winner
a scoring sensation with more than 1 200
career goals
FIFA lowered flags as its Zurich HQ to
half mast the morning after Pele died
aged 82 of multiple organ failure having
battled coal on cancer
at anfield Brazil goalkeeper Alison
Becker LED an Applause with condolences
before Liverpool's Premier League game
against Leicester
I met him once and Around the World Cup
2006 in person I have a signed child
which he gave me my to me for my
birthday
um which is pretty special and so it
feels really tough to be honest
um
yeah
let me say like this I believe in God
and whichever team is playing now for
they got a decent player so everything
will be fine but of course it will be a
massive loss and may your rest in peace
facing Pele on the pitch was a daunting
proposition as Alan mullery experience
playing for Fulham anyone that was going
to play against him you know if you
could stop this player playing and doing
what he did in every game scoring goals
left right and Center then you've
achieved you know greatness in your own
ability to to stop this thing it wasn't
everybody tried everything against him
kicking him knocking him about doing
this doing that if fouling him on on
occasions that nobody else would they
all tried that but Heely and he kept
coming back
as permanent tributes were being Inked
by fans in Brazil dignitaries are
preparing to fly to Sao Paulo to
commemorate football's first Global
Superstar
there will be a 24-hour wait on the
pitch at Santos's Villa belmero Stadium
on Monday and a funeral procession on
Tuesday followed by a private burial for
the player who was the personification
of the beautiful game
Rob Harris Sky News